in the midst of just a packed weekend of
news involving russia ukraine and the
possibility of a biden putin summit and
so many other things
it almost got lost
that a judge has determined donald trump
and his children will have to answer
questions under oath as part of an
investigation this is a massive massive
story a new york judge shot down a bid
to block the state attorney general's
subpoenas of the former president donald
trump jr and ivanka trump
that this is a massive massive story a
judge ordered former president donald
trump and two of his children thursday
to answer questions under oath about the
trump organization's business practices
in the state attorney general's civil
probe against the company remember this
is a civil probe civil
um not
not criminal
lawyers for trump trump jr and ivanka
wanted to quash the subpoenas from
letitia james's office arguing the
investigation is politically motivated
and designed to provide fuel for an
ongoing criminal probe into the company
by the manhattan district attorney's
office in his ruling state supreme court
justice arthur engeron
gave the green light for the three to be
deposed within the next three weeks he
also ordered the former president to
turn over documents and information
subpoenaed within two weeks and
portrayed the trump's claim of being
selectively targeted as overblown
the trump lawyers indicated at a hearing
that they would appeal if anger on let
the depositions proceed quote there is a
lot a likelihood that we will appeal
said alan feuderfass the attorney for
trump's kids
what could happen
if they ultimately do testify
is something called taking the fifth
taking the fifth the associated press
reporting the choice could soon be
trump's in a new york probe
to plead the fifth or not that is the
question donald trump may face
trump's lawyers are almost certain to
appeal the decision
barring a successful legal challenge
trump would face the decision between
answering questions under oath
or remaining silent and invoking his
fifth amendment right a tactic he has
equated with evidence of guilt remember
that
remember trump's previous statements
about people who plead the fifth just a
reminder
fifth amendment
bob
the mob takes if ever
if you're innocent why are you taking
the fifth amendment fifth amendment
horrible
horrible the mob takes if ever
if you're innocent why are you taking
the fifth amendment wow that's a that's
a fair point uh and donald trump uh
speaking about it regularly during the
campaign
her staffers taking the fifth amendment
how about that
and her ringleaders getting immunities
now
she has people taking the fifth
amendment
four people plus
the guy who illegally did the server you
know he put in the illegal server right
so there are five people taking the
fifth amendment like you see on the mob
right
right i see the mob takes it
if you're innocent why are you taking
the fifth amendment that is a beautiful
question now we all know what trump's
going to say if he ends up taking the
fifth he will say no no no listen
those people
were being legitimately looked at
because they did things that were wrong
and they took the fifth so
they're using the fifth is evidence of
their guilt
but for me
these are unfair politically motivated
witch-hunts so it's totally different my
analysis of people pleading the fifth
and that making you look guilty that's
only the case
if you're not me if you're me it's all
politically motivated and blah blah blah
this is genuinely a problem for the
trump family and i think again i want to
restate this is all related to a civil
case not a criminal case
but
it is
important in that it could set precedent
as to whether trump could similarly be
forced to and or uh answer questions
under oath
in a criminal case and we know that
there are multiple investigations uh
looking into whether donald trump has
committed crimes not just civil
infractions or has civil liability so
we're obviously going to be following
this really closely
not the news that trump was hoping for
and this sent trump into full panic mode
and we're going to look at his statement
next
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which makes comprehensive daily
nutrition really simple
people are busy we're not always getting
effective balanced nutrition from the
food we eat
we sometimes are combining all sorts of
different vitamins supplements different
things that may be relevant to us ag-1
by athletic greens is a delicious drink
that just simplifies the entire thing
it's one product you get all of the
things you need 75 vitamins minerals and
whole food sourced ingredients it's a
multivitamin it's a multi mineral it's a
probiotic green food blend
in one daily serving really easy high
quality bio-available ingredients can
fill those nutritional gaps in your diet
and they can help with gut health and
digestion and support you in other ways
and they can replace multiple products
and pills that you might be taking it's
just one drink really simple i've been
enjoying the ag-1 drink by athletic
greens tastes good
helps me get everything i'm trying to
get athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase when you go to
athleticgreens.com
pacman the link is in the podcast notes